remember polar coordinates it's a
circular way of locating a point whereas
rectangular coordinates it's like an
etch-a-sketch kind of a way you know you
can only go left and right up and down
so let's take a look at this point right
here so to get to this point you're
going right X up Y so that's how you
locate the point with polar you're going
out to a circle of radius R and then
you're rotating in angle theta to get to
that same point but what we want to do
is we want to convert from rectangular
coordinates to polar coordinates but
let's take a look at this triangle here
and this will tell us how to convert so
we've got ax squared plus y squared is
equal to R squared right because the
Pythagorean theorem a squared plus B
squared equals C squared
and then if you take the square root of
both sides you can see that the radius
is equal to the square root of x squared
plus y squared ok now with this angle
here if you take the tangent of theta
that's equal to opposite over adjacent
that's why r ax but if you take the
tangent inverse of both sides you can
see that theta is equal to the tangent
inverse of Y over X so these are the two
formulas that we're going to be working
with in this lesson let's look at
example number one to give us the point
negative 3 4 that's XY rectangular
coordinate so we want to get to our
theta so I always like to draw a sketch
I just kind of like to see what's going
on here so left 3 up 4 that's the point
that's the radius we're looking for
that's the angle we're looking for okay
stay with me so far
so what we're going to do is we're gonna
use this first formula over here we've
got the radius is equal to the square
root of x squared so negative 3 squared
plus y squared that's 4 squared so this
comes out to 9 plus 16 square root of 25
is equal to 5 so we know our radius is 5
ok now we want to find the angle so
we're going to be using this formula
over here theta is equal to the tangent
inverse of Y over X ok in this case Y is
4 and X is negative 3 so we're doing the
tangent inverse of 4 over negative 3 now
let me go to the calculator on this one
see what that comes out to we've got
tangent inverse of 4 divided by negative
3 and that's coming out to an A
53.1 but you're probably saying wait a
second Mario that's actually not a
negative 53.1 this is a negative 53.1
here so what you do in that case is
because we're over here in the second
quadrant you'd have to add 180 degrees
tangents restricted from negative 90 to
positive 90 that's why it's giving me
this answer so if we add 180 we're
getting about I'm gonna round to about a
hundred and twenty-seven degrees okay so
that's our angle theta equals 127
degrees if we put it together the radius
and the angle 5 comma 127 degrees that's
our theta and that's our point in polar
coordinates ok so now for example number
two they're giving us X&Y right so two
and two root three and we want to go to
polar R and theta so let's use this
formula R is equal to square root of x
squared plus y squared take the square
root so that comes out to four plus
let's see 2 squared is 4 square root of
3 squared think it's just going to give
you 3 times 4 that's 12 square root of
16 is equal to 4 so that's our radius
and if we want to do our angle now we're
going to do the tangent inverse of Y
divided by X so that's 2 root 3 over 2
you can see the twos cancel
where does tangent equal square root of
3 well you know from your unit circle
the tangents going to equal square root
of 3 let's see that's why over X so
that's going to be right over here
at a 60-degree angle or a 60-degree
angle here in the 3rd quadrant that's
why I like to graph the points so I can
kind of see where on it where I'm at
here I'm right 2 and up 2 or 3 I'm in
the first quadrant ok so that means that
this is a 60-degree angle or we could
say PI over 3 from 1 right in radians so
if we write our final answer R comma
theta 4 comma PI over 3 sometimes
students ask me you know well I put it
in radians or degrees again that's gonna
be up to your teacher they'll let you
know what form that they'd rather have
it in radians or degrees but the key is
the radius and the angle make sure your
graphic to make sure in the correct
quadrant I hope this helped you
understand how to work with polar
coordinates better subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon